Anabella author of in praise of nepotism
and natural history when did you get
this idea I started writing this book in
1998 when I left the Free Press and I
was between jobs it was an idea that I'd
had some years before and my job as an
editor it's it's part of what I do to
come up with ideas for books and try to
get people to to write them and this is
one that I hadn't been able to sell to
anybody else and finally uh a friend of
mine an editor at doubleday suggested
that I might choose to do this subject
myself and it turned out to be a natural
subject for me why well first of all of
course obviously I'm an example of
myself of what I call the new nepotism
and it turned out that it was a very
interesting and I think necessary
challenge to try to account for my own
life experience and my my my career in
publishing in terms of the new nepotism
because when you have the name of a
famous writer and you go into a related
business there's naturally a feeling
that you must have benefited somehow
from from having that that family
connection and in my case and I think in
most cases these days there really
wasn't any direct connection I'm after
my father didn't pick up a phone and ask
a favor get me a job
nevertheless I did come into the
publishing business by the
recommendation of a friend of his Irving
Kristol who referred me to Irwin
cliquish then the publisher of the Free
Press and Irwin decided to take a chance
on me who is Saul Bellow I often asked
that question myself Saul Bellow my
father is a well-known novelist grew up
in Chicago wrote about his experiences
growing up in the depression and during
the 30s and 40s won numerous book prizes
including the Nobel Prize in 1976 I went
to Stockholm to to be part of that and
danced with the queen of Sweden it was a
very exciting experience I was 19 years
old I couldn't get a proper shave didn't
look so good in a tuxedo I felt
it was a very exciting moment and it was
at that point that the spotlight of my
father's celebrity began to include me
after all as a child I'd had no
connection with it but when I became a
college student and then when I went out
into the world I encountered more people
who had heard of my father also of
course many people who hadn't one of my
first jobs like my first job after
college was at the New York Daily News a
real working-class institution I took a
job there as a copy boy I had a romantic
notion of working my way up from the
bottom in journalism I didn't become a
journalist in the end but but it was a
it was a very healthy and enlightening
experience to be working in an
environment where my father's name and
reputation meant nothing conveyed no
privileges people had no interest in me
other than the fact that I stuck out
because I had gone to an Ivy League
school and so I I had the experience of
doing you know sort of I had what I what
I would describe as a as a thorough
classic hazing I was sent around to the
city to do all kinds of low status jobs
and people got a big kick out of the
fact that I had gone to Princeton and
that I was working at this low-paying
job how many years did you live with
your dad well my parents were divorced
when I was an infant I was about a year
and a half old when their marriage broke
up so I was raised by my mother who
worked her whole life to support me we
had very little material support from my
father it wasn't until I entered sixth
grade that my mother prevailed on him to
send me to a private school in New York
City and so the the main benefit that
I've that I had directly from from being
my father's son was that I got a
first-class education and he's how old
today he's 88 years old in year held 46
and what's your relationship with him
now well we're very close I'm pleased to
say as are my two half-brothers my
father's been married a number of times
and I I'm the middle of three sons we
also have a little sister now who's
about three years old
and our relationship deepened when I
went to college and I began to acquire
more education and cultivate more
literary interests and it was at that
point that that we began to have more in
common what is the word nepotism mean
well the word nepotism is generally
sourced to the Latin word
Nepos which means grandson or nephew but
in fact the word nepotism comes from the
Italian of the 16th or 15th century
nepotism au or nepo cheese milk and this
word arose in the context of the
politics of the Catholic Church it was
during this during this period when the
papacy became a very powerful and
wealthy institution that Pope's coming
into office typically gathered their
relatives around them and very often
made nephews or illegitimate children
described as nephews into Cardinals or
or bishops or other high church
officials I wrote this down from page
457 nepotism has always been obnoxious
to Americans well I didn't want it I
wanted to choose a strong word I think
that's I think that's a fairly accurate
description that that hostility to
nepotism clearly goes white right back
to the founding of this country and you
can you can read about it in in a number
of histories of the Revolution at the
time of the Revolution the colonies were
a notorious patronage dump for various
royal favorites and sons and nephews of
of British peers they were sent over
here to to do jobs that local Colonials
would would like to have done themselves
so what we had was in in the 1760s and
70s was a generation of highly educated
ambitious Colonials whose upward
mobility was blocked by the prevalence
of royal favourites in colonial offices
and this led to a very strong initial
prejudice against any kind of hereditary
position
however while the antipathy to nepotism
dates back to the founding and has an I
think an ideological character as a
practical matter nepotism flourished
throughout American history and this is
the thing that I found so fascinating
and in the course of my research when
you look at the history of American
politics business scientific research
and medical practice the American
military the Navy
of course the Academy and literature
what you see on every side are family
traditions and this was the norm this
was the way things were done it was of
course possible in America for a son to
go his own way and make his own path in
life she was a different course but I
think that the majority of sons did not
in the 19th century and the problem
began to be acute towards the end of the
19th century when it became apparent
that American government was filled with
offspring and relations of various kinds
you said something I have never seen in
a book that I would see if I can find
the quote that's quite a distinction I'm
very flattered well I've never seen
anybody say you really don't have to
read that I'll read it
that being the case I should acknowledge
that the book need not be read
sequentially or in its entirety well
this is really a way of appealing to to
the reader and explaining the fact that
I wrote a much longer book than I had
planned to write initially when I first
proposed this book the idea was to write
a short punchy journalistic contrarian
essay called in praise of nepotism the
the idea was to write a book somewhat
like William Henry's book in defense of
a lead ISM which was a best-seller for
Doubleday my publisher and that's what I
set out to do and what happened was that
I the first thing I discovered was that
in the first place no one had ever
written a book about nepotism and having
spent many
in academic settings this made me feel
that I had a real responsibility to
write a comprehensive book and I went on
researching and and thinking about the
subject but oddly enough or not so oddly
being being my father's son
I really couldn't begin to write the
book until I had found the story and I
finally did find the story and the story
is told this is the story told in this
book really in the second half of the
book which is the war on nepotism that
American society has waged the book is
divided into two parts the first part
deals with nepotism in nature and in in
history up until the American Revolution
and what I find there of course which
won't surprise anybody is that in in
other countries and throughout the world
even today nepotism is the norm it is
not just accepted but even expected and
in some cases it's required in in most
human societies throughout history and
throughout much of the world today it is
considered a man's first and highest
duty to aid his relatives and in those
other countries the distinction that we
make between the public and the private
spheres is not very clearly drawn when
you get to the US what you find is first
of all as I said before a very strong
prejudice derived from the founding
against any kind of inherited privilege
and this this is the beginning of the
war on nepotism the war goes through
several distinct phases I I describe
them as a a social phase in which
practices inheritance practices and
marriage practices are reformed
specifically the practice of
primogeniture in which the eldest son
inherits the family estate and the other
children are required to go off find
other other means of subsistence this is
abolished within a couple of years of
the Revolution mainly at the at the
insistence of Thomas Jefferson who had
grown up in Virginia which was dominated
by wealthy families whose whose power
was based on their their large estates
and what Jefferson wanted to accomplish
and he did successfully was to break up
these estates because when you when you
shift from primogeniture to a pattern of
what's called portable inheritance where
the estate is divided equally among the
heirs the family estates tend to
dissipate very quickly a couple of
generations and the families more or
less backward started from and this was
considered by Jefferson and many others
of his of his generation to be a
beneficial thing at the same time
marriage practices are reformed women
acquire the right to divorce and in the
course of the 19th century the rights of
children begin to be supported by
legislation so there's a kind of in this
social phase of history of there's a is
the beginning of really of a war against
patriarchal authority the power of
fathers is reduced by laws and changing
social mores then in the middle of the
century beginning really after the Great
the initial migrations of Irish and
Germans and Italian immigrants there
begins to be a movement for political
reform and I call this the political
phase of the war on nepotism and in this
phase it mainly takes the form of an
attack on political patronage because as
you know from from history when the when
foreign immigrants came to this country
they were largely excluded from
mainstream institutions and so they had
to create their own and some of these
institutions many of them still exist
today for example the Irish created not
just the American Catholic Church which
they used as a as a ladder of social
mobility but also the the political
urban machine which ran on nepotism and
thrived on it on nepotism of every form
not just individual nepotism but but the
larger phenomenon that is described by
some scholars as ethnic nepotism the
idea being you take care of your own and
because nobody else will do so and this
extends to finding people jobs and
getting people set up in the sanitation
department of the police department of
the fire department and these ethnic
traditions by the way persist well into
the 20th century and in fact you I'm
sure you will have noticed after the
World Trade Center disaster
there were lists of of dead firemen and
cops published and
you could see the patterns still the
ethnic patterns still there this these
these these patterns of father-son
succession in working-class professions
continue even today in the third phase
of the war on nepotism the legal fate of
the political things really culminates
in the New Deal
where the at which point the the wasp
upper class comes in to discredit
because they had failed to foresee and
prevent the crash of 29 and during the
depression there was a great deal of
hostility towards family family
privilege and wealth and this gave rise
altom Utley to the legal phase of
nepotism and he of anti-nepotism
activism which begins really in the
post-world War two period and the great
landmark of this phase of the war on
nepotism is the Civil Rights Act of 1965
particularly title 7 which prohibits
discrimination or favoritism based on
race religion ethnicity or gender and
it's at this point that I think you can
say that the old nepotism receives its
its deathblow what then occurs
ironically enough is that after about 20
or 30 years a new form of nepotism
begins to emerge and the thrust of my
argument is that this new American
nepotism is meritocratic that is it
combines the two principles that
Americans hold an equal esteem the
principle of merit and the principle of
family tradition it's a five hundred and
sixty five page book you and your in
your lifetime working for free press and
Doubleday how many books have you
personally edited I haven't ever counted
but i working editor publishes an
average of you know ten books a year or
depending so probably about a hundred
and fifty books over the years what book
is this for you of my own this is my own
misses the only book the first and only
book I've written actually I did write I
do
write a book not for commercial
publication but as a as a job for hire
it was a very interesting project I was
I was hired in the industry that before
I before I went to work in publishing
and I needed I needed income and I was
hired to write a history of a what was
called a settlement house was a was a a
social service institution created in in
the 1880s on the Lower East Side of New
York called the educational alliance and
it was a it was a fascinating assignment
because it was really something allowed
me to investigate a chapter of of Jewish
immigrant history which is of course in
part the story of my life as well the
reason I asked how many books you've
added and when you looked at your own
book were there things that you learned
from editing others that you said I
can't do that I'm gonna lose the reader
well it's an interesting question I
think that it's Avera but I first thing
I have to say I discovered it's a very
different thing to be an author and it's
very hard to edit yourself after all
after four years of working on this book
I'd produced a manuscript of well in
excess of 800 pages and I was really at
a loss as to how to bring it down to a
manageable size and that's where my
editor Jerry Howard at Doubleday proved
indispensable because he was able to see
where I could not how in what places I
was going into to great detail so the
writing of the book took about three
years we spent the better part of a
fourth year cutting it down to at least
a manageable size now you work a double
day I do now did you when you first got
this contract no I didn't and of course
it's very unusual for for an editor who
is publishing a book too to be working
at the house where he's being published
it isn't it isn't normally considered
appropriate or we just say a good idea
and but my status is a little bit
different at Doubleday I'm not on the
staff I don't have a staff position I'm
what's called an editor at large so
while I have an office there and and an
assistant
I am NOT a full participant in the life
of the house in certain respects so in
some respects you it's a little bit of
nepotism being at doubleday and having
an editor at doubleday and did that
cause a problem based on your own
experience when you're at Free Press
when nobody I assume very few people on
Free Press wrote a book and that you
edited there well this certainly that
didn't happen although Free Press at the
time when I worked there was part of
Simon & Schuster and the the model for
this kind of dual career of writer and
editor was was Michael kurta who was a
great and distinguished editor at Simon
& Schuster who also has published many
books but Michael did not publish his
books with Simon & Schuster he went
elsewhere to do so I think that in this
case it was understood to be an anomaly
but what happened was that first I was
signed up to to write a book and then
there was one of those periodic
managerial and staff changes at at
Doubleday the the old editorial team
left and a new team came in and I had to
go in and talk to them and make sure
that they first of all they still wanted
to publish my book because no one wants
to be orphaned this is that the term
that is used for for authors who lose
their editor they're orphans and an
orphaned book often has difficulty
finding its way to a successful
publication so I really needed to to
establish a rapport with the new people
and I found they were terrific very
welcoming and supportive and not only
did they suffer their interest in
publishing my book which was already
late by the way
but they they offered me a position as
an editor at large because they wanted
to publish they wanted to add to their
list a certain kind of nonfiction you
know edgy political or public affairs
kind of thing that I'm known for doing
what my first reaction when I got into
this book was I don't know how you took
on all these names all in their many
BIOS in here many biographies any one of
these chapters could almost be a full
book how did you and named some of the
people that you write about
I can start with Jesus well yes in all
of these the problem that I had when I
sat down to write this book was that no
one as I said before no one had ever
written a book about nepotism and so it
was necessary to derive or extract the
relevant information from numerous
biographical books and what I found was
so I sat down and I read many books
about Jesus and his family for example
there was there's a good deal of
controversy about this I don't I don't
want to take sides but there does seem
to be a scholarly consensus that the
family of Jesus was very important in
the life of the early church and in fact
after Jesus's death the Jerusalem church
was taken over by his brother James and
his message was was promulgated by his
relatives and there was a struggle for
control of the Christian message between
James the brother of Jesus and Paul who
was a convert and not a not a family
member and Paul wanted to universalize
the message of Jesus he wanted to bring
that message to the Gentiles to the
peoples of the Roman Empire and the
relatives of Jesus wanted to keep his
message in the family in effect they
wanted it to be a Jewish a Jewish sect
and the of course the outcome was that
Paul won out and the the universal
Church founded by Paul and Peter won out
in the end there were Jewish Christians
who's adhered to the original teachings
preserved by the family of Jesus for
another century at least eventually
however they were they were outnumbered
by the Gentile Church founded by Peter
and Paul then and and help me with the
pronunciation the Borgias the Borgia
family guess what I what I've done is to
go through European history and American
history and I've selected the stories of
representative families that that are
very well known I didn't want to go for
obscure families because
the what was I thought was more
interesting was to tell retell the story
a very well-known families from the
angle from this particular perspective
of how nepotism was useful to them in
their rise through European society to
to the heights of power so in the
chapter devoted to European history in
what I call the Golden Age of nepotism
which is a period extending more or less
from the Renaissance to the French
Revolution I focused on the Borgia
family a family of Spanish clerics who
became popes there were two boards of
popes within the span of a generation
and the the the Bonaparte's and the
Rothschild and the reason that I
selected these three families first of
all is because they're very well known
and I thought it would be interesting to
people who are familiar with there but
with their biographies to look at them
from this angle of how they used family
ties and connections to rise to rise
through European society but I also
wanted to illustrate the three main
avenues of social mobility open at that
time to ambitious dynastic family
founders the church the military and the
market because these were the only ways
in a society where wealth was largely
based on land these were the only ways
in which you could rise from a middling
status to an aristocratic one well then
later you onto the Adams 'iz and the
Roosevelts and the Kennedys and some of
the bushes who all you're reading and
how could you have any idea how many
books you had to read to get ready for
this I have an excellent idea III made
use of the New York University Library
because that it's it's close to my to my
home in Manhattan and I checked out from
that library about 300 books which I
which I kept in my office and and
consulted I also in addition to that I
either bought or or read parts of
another 150 books I must have I must
have consulted about 500 books
altogether when you say consulted does
that mean you didn't read the whole book
no you don't have to read the whole book
it's it's what happens is you develop a
kind of an eye for the for the telling
detail what I find very interesting is
that this subject has just been
neglected this aspect of of family
history has been neglected by most
biographers nevertheless you do find the
occasional detail for example Teddy
Roosevelt's career I find this a
marvelous example I mean Teddy Roosevelt
was the son of a very well known and
respected New York philanthropist of the
Roosevelt's had been rich for several
generations and Teddy Teddy's father
Theodore Roosevelt senior was a leader
of the political reform movement that
arose in the 1880s he was he was one of
these blueblood reformers who felt that
it was it was necessary for the
aristocratic figures in Americans
decided to get back into public life
because it had become a sinkhole of
corruption and Teddy's father was much
beloved and and when he died suddenly
Teddy was left without a father and so
he turned to his uncle Robert Barnwell
Roosevelt a very colorful figure in his
own right he usually is mentioned in the
biographies of Teddy because he was so
colorful he was he was for example a
bigamist he had a second family around
the corner that nobody knew about for
for many many years and after this was
revealed Teddy was the only one who
would who would continue to speak with
him uncle Barnwell was instrumental in
Teddy's rise when Teddy decided to go
into politics this was considered in bad
form it was considered bad form and bad
taste by his family because an
aristocratic person like Teddy Roosevelt
shouldn't have sullied his hands with
with the business of politics but his
uncle Barnwell was very prominent in the
Democratic Party in New York and put him
in touch with important people in New
York state politics as a result Teddy
was able to run for the state assembly
at the age of 23 he was completely
untried and untested he had just gone to
Harvard and and there's a marvelous
description
of the debate about whether Teddy should
be allowed to stand for office and of
course the fact that he was an
unexperienced an untried young man and
the son of a rich rich family was was
brought up and held against him but one
of the New York papers editorialized
that young mr. Roosevelt had a
hereditary claim on the confidence of
the voters of New York and because of
his father's great services to the to
the city and state and I was very struck
by that I mean this is something that
you find in a if you pass over cash and
most people just pass over this casually
you know in a biography but it's very
revealing because it's not a statement
that could be made today as you can
imagine nobody would nobody
no newspaper would say such a thing but
it does reflect a prevailing attitude
and I think it is an unspoken attitude
among many Americans today after all
look at the numbers of of Kennedy's who
who go into politics you know what's the
justification for that family tradition
people are of course have mixed feelings
about the Kennedys but the fact is the
family has done great services for the
country and American voters in general
seem quite willing to give a young
Kennedy the benefit of the doubt even
John F Kennedy jr. who was considered
you know not the brightest light in the
Kennedy in the Kennedy family would
undoubtedly have been embraced by a
majority of New York voters if he had
chosen to run for office jump to the
George Bush situation for a moment would
he be President of the United States in
your opinion if he wasn't the son of
George Herbert Walker Bush well
certainly not I don't think I don't
think anybody thinks that and of course
there has been a good deal of debate
about this and coincidentally it began
to become an issue about the same time
that I began to write my book I mean I
signed my contract in 1998 and that was
the that was the year in which both
George Bush and Al Gore announced their
intention to run
for their respective party's nominations
and right away the mud began to fly and
the two men were compared as signs of of
political families it was my feeling of
course the outcome of the election has
been contested and I'm not I'm not I'm
not sure that I want to say that that
Americans weren't bothered at all by the
fact that that George Bush had these
inherited connections but I do think
it's fair to say that they were less
bothered by them than many intellectuals
and journalists thought they should be
the public at large seemed to have the
same attitude towards George Bush in
2000 that the New York public had about
Teddy Roosevelt when he ran for office
which is to say you know let's give him
let's give him a chance and I think the
outcome shows that at any rate whether
you feel that he was elected with a with
a popular mandate or not it's clear that
he did much better than anybody expected
that he should be considering that he
didn't have the kind of national
political experience that Al Gore had
would John Quincy Adams our sixth
president be had bet would he have been
elected president if it hadn't been for
his father I don't think he would have
because he owed his entire career even
though he was I think John Quincy Adams
is was very like Al Gore in being a very
hard-working
dutiful son who felt obliged and really
driven to prove his merit on his own
terms but it is clear from history that
John Quincy would not have become
Secretary of State for example as you as
he did unless his father had pulled
strings during the Washington
administration to get him assigned as a
diplomat in Europe now John Adams his
father was a great stickler for merit
and he didn't wish to be seen to be
helping his son although he was very
ambitious for you
John Quincy and John Quincy wrote in his
diary on many occasions that uh that he
was that he felt a tremendous pressure
from his father and from his mother
let's not leave out Abigail
or any of the dynastic mothers who I
think are very important in the in the
story of nepotism but George Washington
intervened to relieve John Adams of the
burden of conflict and ambivalence and
he simply became the young man's patron
and even interceded with the father when
the father became president - as he put
it in a letter not to withhold deserved
promotion for mr. John Adams simply
because he is your son did John Quincy
Adams want to be President he did very
very much so the the Adams is always as
a family believed in their in their
destiny to be leaders and Democratic
statesmen and they all felt superbly
qualified to to to be political figures
and they all were in in certain respects
it's a very interesting family and it's
been well it's been well documented it's
it is clear that the father and son were
alike in certain in this respect that
they were not very good as presidents
their their contributions to American
politics were were stronger in other
areas particularly in diplomacy you
write a lot about Abraham Lincoln he you
know what relationship did he have to
his father or his family well Lincoln is
the great is the great counterexample
Lincoln has always held up as the the
model of the self-made man the person
who who rose from humble obscurity to
become president of the country based
simply on his merit and Worth and I read
many biographies of Lincoln not with the
intention of debunking this myth because
it was it is it is acknowledged to be a
myth in it I wouldn't be the first one
to say so
after all Lincoln was already a very
successful lawyer railroad lawyer and in
Springfield before well before he went
into politics
and but but I did feel that blinken had
to be dealt with and what I found is
very interesting which is that first of
all Lincoln came from a family that had
a record and a long really a long
history of public service his own father
of course was a failure and had migrated
West like many other people looking for
for greater opportunities and he he
bought and failed again and again with
with many farms he kept moving from one
state to another finally ended up in
freeze Kentucky Indiana Illinois and and
the relationship between Abe and his
father was was very was very strained
and harsh the father wanted able to to
stay on the farm and contribute to the
family enterprise and Abe wanted to go
off on his own so it's a very romantic
situation Abe finally did go off on his
own and what I what I argue is that
Lincoln had to become adept at forming
friendships and and alliances with
people who could help him and he had a
genius for this kind of thing he was he
was famous for striking up front
lifelong friendships and on a moment's
notice and and he did climb on the rungs
of these relationships to a very
prominent position in the Illinois
Republican Party one of the most
important things that he did to help
himself was to marry Mary Todd Mary Todd
was a person it was a woman who came
from a from a very well-respected
wealthy Kentucky family they were
slave-owning family and she was related
by marriage to the circle of Illinois
politicians known as the Springfield
junto so one of the one of the under
under discussed features of American
political history all over America in
the 19th century there were these what
were called Jun tous it's a it's a
Spanish where to hunt ax but it really
describes a cabal a group of people who
have common political and
business interests and generally
intermarry in order to strengthen these
bonds and in order to get ahead in
particularly in a provincial area like
Illinois you had to have some connection
to this group of people and Lincoln by
marrying Mary Todd acquired a marital
connection to the Springfield junto and
it was the making of him he became the
leading lawyer in the state he was put
up for he'd already been to Congress I
mean and not to Congress but to the
state assembly where he had performed
very significant services particularly
the most important service was getting
the State Capitol moved from Vandalia to
Springfield where the members of the
Gento could exploit this this this move
the business that would come with it and
his reward was really to to be allowed
to marry into the junto later on these
friendships and relationships were very
instrumental in helping him to to rise
to national office well you know as I
again went to the book I thought how
does he get all this stuff I mean
there's an enormous amount of ground
that you cover go back to your the way
you put the book together when you when
you got those 300 books out of the New
York Public Library were you allowed to
keep them at home for three years well
you know I am very grateful to the New
York University Library and the way that
a university like Merrick University
write and the way it works is that you
can check out books you have to pay for
the privilege as a as a as a borrower
because I'm not a I'm not attached to
the university at all but I pay them an
annual fee and I'm allowed to check out
books and keep them at home and I can
renew them online so that I don't have
to in the in the first year and a half I
actually had to carry the books you know
physically back to the library and have
them stamped again over the course of
the four years that I wrote this book
the NYU library entered the 21st century
and so it became possible for me to just
type in my my code number and my books
would be renewed the reason I asked is
what was it what was the normal daylight
for you how did you immerse yourself in
this book where did you write the book
what was the how did you go about this
to keep all this straight because you
know I mean the reason I'm asking is you
know that any chapter on any subject can
be parsed by all kinds of historians
well it was the opportunity of a
lifetime
as all I can say I was just on fire with
enthusiasm for this subject particularly
because I knew that no one had ever done
this before I was I was plowing virgin
territory and it was tremendously
exciting I mean I can't emphasize enough
how how exciting and thrilling it is for
an author to be writing a book on a
subject that no one has ever has ever
written about and this gave me a
tremendous sense of motivation and also
a sense of obligation I really felt that
I had to do this in a way that we really
would be unimpeachable and this gets me
into a another subject which is which
really is the question of what kind of a
book how good does my book have to be in
order to withstand the kind of scrutiny
that it's likely to receive after all I
am the son of Saul Bellow
and there there were bound to be
comparisons drawn you know you you're
the children of famous people when they
win it when they go into their parents
profession even on a parallel track as I
as I have chosen to do I mean I'm not a
novelist I don't want to compete with my
father directly I don't want to be
compared with him directly but even even
though I went into a nonfiction track I
knew that that the standards and
expectations would be higher for me than
for for most other people so I I
laboured to produce a book that could
not be impeached casually but people no
one could really no one could say I
hadn't done my homework
perhaps this was maybe I overdid it it's
possible that I was little too earnest
in my in my efforts to to to build this
book in a way that that would withstand
those kinds of comparisons but at the
same time my experience as an editor and
I've published many as I said published
many books some of them are still in
print most of them are not and what I
realized over the years as as an editor
and publisher is that if you want your
book to last you have to build it to
last and that's what that's what my
ambition was I wanted to build a book
that would that would last longer than a
season or two
and I hope I've succeeded in doing that
now what's the daylight well I have to
earn a living in addition to being a
writer I do acquire and edit and publish
books for Doubleday so I had an office
there and it was filled with my research
materials and also the manuscripts that
I that I worked on and I simply go in
there I'd be there I went in very early
usually there by 8 o'clock and I would
stay till about 6:00 or 6:30 and I was
often in the office on weekends in fact
general usually on weekends and when we
went for a family vacation I had to have
a little room off to the side where I
could hole up and do my work and this
became a way of life for me and for my
family your family consists of I'm
married and I have two daughters age
ages 16 and 11 we live in New York City
in Soho and for the first two years I I
worked at home and I had a little office
at home but my wife had to give up her
nonprofit institution that she was
running and so she started working at
home and I had to I had to use office
space at Doubleday so when you again the
techniques did you did you do it on a
laptop or on your on your desk computer
well I have a laptop at home and I have
a desktop computer at doubleday
I made extensive use of online research
services you can do a great deal of
research now from your computer you
don't have to visit every every
collection so I was able to to pursue my
threads of my interest through through
the books that I checked out through the
through the research services available
online and then there would be
interruptions you know I'd have a couple
of hours to work and then I'd have to
set my work aside and work on somebody
else's book or I'd have to to read
proposals and circulate them and get get
my colleagues to agree to sign the book
and I you know I worked very hard I mean
it was it was it was difficult if if
that's what you're asking
well no when did you did you write each
of these chapters I mean if you once you
did your research would you write a
chapter and then move on and research
the next one how did you do that well
it's not it's not entirely clear to me
how I did it or what my what my method
was I was researching because I was
covering the entire span of human
history and I had to I had to I've spent
I have one chapter on the biology of
nepotism which I spent about a year and
a half
writing and rewriting but at the same
time I was also working on other parts
of the book and actually it wasn't until
I was about halfway through the process
that the shape of the book emerged and
that I began to understand as I said you
know took me a while to figure out what
the storyline was because there's a lot
of material and we don't want to write a
boring a repetitive book when I
discovered that the story I was telling
was really on the largest scale it's the
story of the interaction between the
family and the state the difficulties
after all nepotism doesn't really become
doesn't really emerge as a concept until
the creation of the Catholic Church
which is the first in the Western
history the first large-scale
bureaucratic organization you'd had
concerns about you had inhibit ISM
emerge as a problem to some extent in
the previous millennium in the in the
context of the Chinese Imperial
bureaucracy and some of the other great
bureaucracies of the ancient world the
the Roman and Byzantine bureaucracies
for example nepotism was considered to
be a bit of a problem but it was more or
less winked at because frankly the the
government didn't pay bureaucrats very
much and it was expected the certain
amount of corruption was expected and
whenever there is corruption of that
kind nepotism is always involved after
all you know people in in ancient China
were enjoined to to look after their
families and when a person became a
bureaucratic official who was expected
by everybody
most of all the relatives that he would
he would do things to take care of them
and also bring other people into the
bureaucracy when they were opportunities
to do so but it isn't until the middie
till the medieval or Renaissance period
when the Catholic Church became a really
powerful and important organization that
nepotism was identified as a problem and
somehow a solution had to be found and
as you go forward in European history
from that point as this as national
states emerge and bureaucratic
institutions are created the the drama
begins to heighten because what what
happens is this you have a really
preface this by saying people think of
nepotism in America very narrowly and
this is the first thing that I that I
really wanted to say and this is the
thing that I that I that I find myself
saying when when I'm confronted with
with the natural indignation that
Americans feel after all it's outrageous
for me to suggest that anything good
could be said about nepotism but the
reason that seems outrageous is simply
an artifact of the narrow and arbitrary
way in which we define nepotism today we
define nepotism as not just as favoring
a relative over over somebody else as a
stranger it's implied that the relative
is less competent this is a reflection
of American prejudice against nepotism
it's an assumption that many people
share that your relatives are
objectively going to be less qualified
than then a more qualified stranger and
so you what you find again and again is
that you you find people assuming that
the majority of cases of nepotism are
negative that the nepotism is a bad
thing that doesn't work out as one
reviewer said nepotism has earned its
bad reputation actually it from a study
of history I find this is completely
untrue it's absolutely the reverse and
the greatest the best example of this is
American business and this is something
I really want to emphasize when I got
into this subject I didn't realize
extensive nepotism really is and of
course it's very visible in politics
today it's very visible in Hollywood and
and you can debate it's legitimate to
debate just how much family succession
ought to go on in any of these
supposedly meritocratic sectors but most
nepotism occurs in the business world
and it is an astonishing fact but about
95 percent of all American businesses
are still family owned or controlled
there's 24 million family businesses in
this country and they're all being you
know left to first of all not just left
but they're there they draw on family
members for for for their for their
labor and they're generally left to
family members and I think it's very
clear and I hope persuasive to say that
if nepotism weren't on the whole a
positive thing America the American
economy would be a basket case but of
course it isn't it's a thriving engine
of prosperity so I think you have and if
so that's the first thing I want to say
about nepotism that that really has a
bad rap and that it doesn't deserve now
historically when you look at nepotism
from historical point of view what I
find there's another interesting thing
which is that an epoch ISM has in
practice differently at different times
in different cultural contexts and it's
an evolving thing and it evolves in
relation specifically to the growth of
state institutions and then the market
of course and the beneficiary of
beneficiaries of nepotism have largely
been the upper class and the lower
classes and the immigrant classes
because at both these levels of society
nepotism has been practiced freely and
openly for hundreds and hundreds of
years it's the middle class that has the
prejudice against nepotism and the
reason for that in my my argument is
that the middle class rose to prosperity
through these institutions that were
created in the early modern period
through the through the army the
state the marketplace and these are
institutional settings in which merit
and efficiency are necessary and are
rewarded generally and this is the case
now in America we have we still have
today an upper-class variety of nepotism
where you have very large extended
families you know who have like the
bushes and the Kennedys we have
compounds family compounds in you know
in remote places where nobody's allowed
to go and and they they help one another
they invest with one another there they
do business together they socialize
together by preference and they make
careful marriages as well but also at
the lower-class level among
working-class and immigrant communities
nepotism
is still the way things are done and
again you know one of the prejudices
that people have about nepotism is that
it's all about class privilege it's
somehow you know nepotism is considered
to be a disease of the rich and that the
only people who practice it are wealthy
people who are we're allowed to buy
privileges for their children but the
truth is quite quite the opposite that
that nepotism is the traditional way in
which working-class people and
particularly immigrant communities have
pulled together and helped helped one
another and middle-class people in this
country have by and large conveniently
forgotten that their position in the
middle class as doctors or lawyers or
engineers or what-have-you is generally
owed to two or three generations of
ethnic nepotism can you remember when
you were conscious of your father as a
writer where and then can you remember
where you decided I'm gonna be a writer
oh sure I was very young and that's
really all I knew about my father really
because I didn't live with him when I
was five six seven years old I wanted to
know everybody else had a daddy and I
wanted to know they all you know they're
better that we've come to school and
they would say what their fathers did I
didn't really didn't know what my father
did and I had to ask my mother and she
said your father's a writer well I
didn't really know what that meant
but it's overtime of course I became
more aware of it I think very early on I
decided that I wanted to be a writer and
I think it's very common for children of
accomplished parents to just to make
that choice because what I find in
reading the accounts that various
successors today give of their motives
for going into the family business is
that they want to be close to their
parents very very often as you know
successful and accomplished people are
often distant and absent and distracted
and preoccupied and so the children
really have a psychological need to to
get their parents attention and and they
often choose to do this by following in
their footsteps by the way you saw
Bethel wrote what are some of the big
names of the knowledge erode well his
his first really famous novel was The
Adventures of Augie March which was
published I believe 1953 before my
before I was born
Henderson the rain King Hertzog are his
some of his other better known books and
most recently his last novel was called
Ravel Stein which was a portrait of the
late Allan bloom was a very close friend
of it now have you ever had anybody
analyzed the way you write in the way he
writes well no I have not
but I I it may it may happen I I'm
conscious of certain echoes of my
father's prose style and but not just
his prose style but his way of speaking
give us an example well he has a way of
well first of all I guess what you're
really asking me is is how much like my
father am I or the opposite of that how
much different are you well I think
you'd have to ask my wife in a way to
for that the answer to that question I
mean one difference between us is that
I've been married for 16 or 17 years and
my father has had five marriages so
there's clearly a difference there and
in fact all both of my brothers are are
committed monogamists whereas our father
was was known for for having liaisons
and girlfriends so I'm really actually
talking about the writing part of it
though yeah I mean I know you know I'm
you're watching this a little bit I'm
not sure how to answer your question I
think this is a certain kind of tonality
and I mean look at it this way my father
came from a immigrant impoverished
immigrant environment multilingual he
grew up in the in his home speaking
Yiddish and Russian and English and some
French because the family lived in
Montreal and this developed allowed
these sources allowed him out of these
sources he developed a very distinctive
voice it's it's ironic it's sort of you
know Jewish but also high-faluting it's
until very intellectual so this is the
kind of marriage of high and low that
you find in his prose and give so much
energy to his writing I also the the wit
is he's famous he's very very funny both
on the page and in person and I grew up
in an environment where we're we're
literacy literary literary education and
wit a certain kind of earthy puncturing
penetrating wit were very valued so I
learned to to use language in a way from
him that I think I wouldn't have learned
from anybody else of all the characters
you wrote about in the book is there
anybody that you got interested enough
and then you might expand on it later or
if you don't do that is who was your
favorite character well I think my
favorite character in this book is the
father of Napoleon Bonaparte a man who
has been I think unfairly reviled and
his bad reputation begins with Napoleon
himself and as I write in the book that
the section devoted to the Bonaparte
family is really about Napoleon's father
because Napoleon is considered to be the
great self-made man of them
Neera you know the example of a young
fatherless young man who isn't even
really French comes from from Corsica
rises through the mill of French
military to the heights of political
power brings his brothers and sisters
along with him of course and takes care
of them but he always a Napoleon always
ascribed his success it's pretty much to
his own genius and ability and what I
found when I looked into the the story
of the Bonaparte family is that
Napoleon's father Carlo Bonaparte a was
really underestimated by his own
children and I think you know in a sad
and ungrateful way this is the story of
a man who really devoted his entire life
to getting his children into the system
of French nobility we just have a moment
left and I have to ask you about this
cover whose idea was it and for those
that you can't tell her that's that's a
raised silver spoon well I was not part
of this discussion
you know authors are not invited to
participate in jacket meetings so I
don't know exactly whose idea it was but
I do know that there was some difficulty
figuring out how to illustrate this book
and somebody I think it was Bill Thomas
the editorial director at Doubleday said
well something this is really about
inherited privilege and isn't it
commonly said that you know the people
are people with inherited privileges are
born with the silver spoon in their
mouth and everybody seemed to think that
was a wonderful idea and the resulting
jacket I think is one of the one of the
most beautiful striking and elegant
jackets I've ever seen in publishing
that's our time and this is again what
the cover looks like and our guest has
been Adam Bello the name of this book is
in praise of nepotism thank you very
much thank you Brian